it's so nice to have you here you're one
of my all-time favorite guests
uh always entertaining uh we've had such
a good time together over the years
you know we really have yeah it sucks
that you're renting this i'm
ending this version of it i'll come back
with a cooking show or something
what are you doing you're going to be on
what hbo max are you allowed to say that
on this network are they going to get
upset
no no they're cool with it i think
they're all aren't they all the same
thing
they're all in bed together by the same
everybody i mean
everybody's owned by one company now
we're all working for exxon
so yeah while working for exxon and they
have a very low budget exactly
they don't have a lot of money that
reminds me back in the day when i used
to do like
chappelle show yeah that was like viacom
and that was the funniest thing ever
they'd always be like we don't have a
lot of money
so you'd like book a part they'd be like
yeah you're playing a swat guy do you
have any combat boots
and you'd be like yeah no i don't any of
your friends
do your friends and they're viacom
but it was just like this isn't my job
my job's to book the part
so we would just give the ladies [ __ ]
down there going hey you play you're
playing a
a blacksmith you got an anvil any of
your friends do you know
can you get one let's lug it over here
it's like no i'm not doing them
i don't know that's always been uh yeah
i've been paid a lot in exposure
throughout the years this is great
exposure i'm just going to trash
everything i've ever done
i love the 80s strikes back that was
this great exposure it's great exposure
they wouldn't
we had to fight them to give us cab fare
granted it wasn't the highest art bill
what would you do for a klondike bar
well i'll tell you
remind me back in the day i worked in a
restaurant in north carolina that was
slowly going out of business
and at one point i was the best boy
slowly slowly always it was a
slow bad day they put a five-star
restaurant in the middle of this stupid
strip mall
it was doomed from the beginning so um
not to mention it was sort of the 80s so
a lot of people were uh you know
they were ready to work we'll put it
that way yeah um
amped up um i was the busboy i was the
grill chef
kicked on a mesquite grill and the
dishwasher all at the same time i
remember those
[ __ ] thinking about it this morning
this is that irish thing where you never
let [ __ ] go
yeah i came running in the back i taken
off my chef half i ran out
and i bust the tables i came in the back
and i said hey we're out of glasses
and this guy who was on work release
from prison
he goes well why don't you wash some and
he goes
ah a novel idea
i remember he said like he was this
well-read guy
this guy was on work released from
prison i was like hey how about you
don't
go to jail you [ __ ] convict piece of
[ __ ]
and i'm doing three other jobs but
this is the deal he was in jail so i was
scared so i was like
okay and then i just washed them and
probably burned the shrimp brochettes
that's a tragic story